(upbeat music)
- Hello, everyone, welcome back.
I'm Rebecca Finlay, and
I am very pleased to be
moderating and leading
this final panel of the day
on AI policy.
Bonjour a tous.
One note, please remember you can join
into the conversation on social media
by tagging CIFAR news on Twitter,
with the hashtag AICAN.
And we are going to end the
panel with your questions.
And so please submit
your questions through
the zoom Q&A function,
at the bottom of the screen
and I will try to get to them
at the end of the panel.
The focus of the session
is on AI and Policy.
And as Minister Shang
Pang affirmed so clearly,
in his remarks this morning,
the government of Canada has committed
to developing and implementing policies
that promote trust
in a digital world and keep pace
with the rapid technological
development of AI.
We know for example, about the launch
of the digital charter in May of 2019,
and then the recent legislation
proposed through bill C-11,
the digital charter implementation act
in November of 2020
alongside all sorts of
international efforts
including the Global Partnership on AI.
And as the minister kindly
mentioned this morning,
CIFAR's AI and society program.
Part of the Pan-Canadian AI strategy,
this program supports working groups
on a range of topics related
to social political and
economic impacts of AI.
And most recently with
the generous partnership
of IDRC focusing on a call
for AI governance solutions
in low to middle income countries.
Canada is fortunate.
We have a rich community
of experts and advocates
committed to charting a path
to responsible AI governance.
We have offices of information
and privacy commissioners
across the country,
AI and social science
researchers and legal experts,
as well as human rights and
civil society organizations
taking up the cause.
And we are very lucky,
because we have some
of those leaders with
us today on this panel.
So I am going to introduce them.
And as I do, please take a moment to share
in the chat, the top
three things that come
to mind for you,
about AI policy in Canada.
So please join me in welcoming four
remarkable individuals who are going
to join today's discussion.
First, we have Golnoosh Farnadi.
Golnoosh is the Canda CIFAR AI chair,
a member of MILA,
and an assistant
professor at HEC Montreal.
She is a leader in algorithmic fairness
in machine learning, and decision-making
causality and interpretability.
Great to have you with us Golnoosh.
Also Patricia Kosseim.
Patricia is Ontario's Information
and Privacy Commissioner,
with a wealth of knowledge
in privacy and access law
and extensive experience in the public
private and health sectors.
I for one think we are very lucky
to have you in Ontario, Patricia.
So thanks so much for joining us.
Then we have Deborah Raji.
Deborah is a researcher
and a Mozilla fellow.
In 2020 she was named one of
the top innovators under 35,
by MIT technology review
for her research on racial and gender bias
in facial recognition systems.
Deborah, great to have you with us.
Thank you so much.
And finally, we have Jacques Rajotte.
Jacques is a lawyer and a leader
in International Development,
who is currently the
Interim Executive Director
of the International Center
of Expertise in Montreal
for the advancement of AI, for
the global partnership on AI.
Thanks so much Jacques.
So let's get underway.
I would really welcome
hearing from the four of you,
on sort of a, with a very broad question
just to reflect briefly
for us to get started
in sort of three minutes ish.
Perhaps respond to the question,
what do you think Canada
is doing well with respect
to AI policy and where do
you think we can improve?
And Commissioner Patricia,
why don't we start with you?
- Thank you Rebecca.
And thank you for the
invitation to be here.
I'm very honored
to be joining this panel of
wonderful colleagues who am I've just had
the pleasure of meeting.
It's always wonderful to meet new faces
and new people in this space.
And so thank you for that opportunity.
So, in terms of what Canada is doing well
in terms of AI leadership,
I'm gonna speak about privacy aspects
of that AI leadership in particular.
And I would say that,
from my perspective, I
think Canada is quite
an influential actor on
the international stage,
punching way above its
weight, relatively speaking
in terms of privacy leadership.
And to be clear, I'm not
talking about legal instruments
which are sorely lagging behind,
but I'm talking about
concrete policy actions
that Canada has spearheaded.
And there are several reasons for this.
First, as you alluded to Rebecca,
we have a federal system,
of course, here in Canada
which means we have 14 jurisdictions,
each with its own Commissioner
or data protection regulator.
And as we say in French,
(speaks in foreign language)
this certainly strengthens our capacity,
our involvement and our collective voice
on the international stage,
and in particular, our role
in the global privacy assembly
which just this year, for instance
this past year
adopted a resolution
which our office co-sponsored
on accountability,
responsible accountability in AI.
Second, we've had a
really strong and steady
cadre of commissioners,
who by their own individual personalities,
interests and priorities have
taken a very proactive stance
in the international arena.
And I'm thinking here for instance
of the influential concept
of privacy by design
that was minted by my
predecessor here in Ontario
and has become an integral
component of the EU GDPR,
among other modern privacy
regimes around the world.
The previous federal commissioner,
has had a very influential
role in updating
the OECD guidelines
on privacy and security, and,
really was instrumental in
building the foundations
for international enforcement cooperation.
We're seeing made possible today
between data protection
authorities around the globe.
The current Federal Privacy
Commissioner has been, I mean,
very significant behind
the scenes contributions
to strengthening the governance structure
of the global privacy assembly.
And one of our former
commissioners in Canada from BC,
has gone on to take the
leadership of the UK
information commissioner's office
which is probably the largest DPA
or data protection affiliate in the world.
Third I'd say, given the
absence of an overarching
federal privacy law in the U S
at least in the private sector,
this has really allowed
Canada to take a highly
credible persuasive leadership role,
vis-a-vis our counterparts
internationally,
without being overshadowed
by our neighbors
to the South for change.
And forth, I think we've
built a very strong
privacy research capacity in Canada.
Thanks to some amazing research programs
you mentioned Rebecca and to name
I think some of them
would include, you know,
the large scale social science projects,
we've seen dedicated to
privacy funded by Shirk,
the consumer interest
research program funded
by innovation science
and economic development,
privacy research funded by
the office of the privacy commissioner.
And not to mention the
interdisciplinary research
programs prompted by CIA (murmurs)
ethics and knowledge translation programs.
Genome Canada's integrated GELS programs,
and of course CIFAR's
AI and society program.
So many of these opportunities have helped
our Canadian privacy
researchers gain visibility
on the international stage
and have some very significant influence.
So, this is of course
as I said, you know,
concrete policy action.
And while our actions have
been louder than words,
I think it's high time
for our words to catch up.
And I'm talking specifically about
to the need to modernize
Canada's privacy statutes,
but my three minutes are up.
So I'll leave you in suspense.
And I'm gonna talk a little bit more
about that later on in the panel.
- Great, thank you, Patricia.
And I love to think about the words
and the power of words
and the need for that.
And when we think about
what we're doing today
in terms of bringing
these communities together
so thanks so much.
- Deborah, would you like
to take a moment to reflect
on that question for us?
- Yeah, for sure.
I think I'm sort of probably
gonna take a little bit
of a broader lens to things,
in terms of to start off
things that I think Canada
is doing very well, and is very impressive
is just the agile policy
development especially with,
the algorithmic impact
assessments and that effort
incredibly at the department
of treasury I believe,
it's incredibly impressive
how sort of quickly
that group was able to
iterate on that idea
and how, you know,
that effort has really stood
as an example for a
lot of other countries.
A lot of the work I do is in the U S
and in the American context.
And even in that context, it's really,
sort of a gold standard in terms of
quickly iterating on, you know,
documentation practice for policy purposes
and doing that, you know,
at a pace that's not typical
of policy development in general.
So, yeah, very impressed with the
algorithmic impact assessment effort
and how quickly that was able to
be piloted, and how quickly
it was able to iterate.
And also connecting that
with different stakeholders
in different ways to
really make that effective.
So, yeah, that's definitely
something I think
Canada is doing very well.
Also, Patricia already mentioned this
but I think the privacy by design effort
is also quite impressive.
I do a lot of work in facial recognition
and that work has been
incredibly influential
in terms of the policy
development in that space.
You know, a lot of the standards
for data storage and data
distribution is sort of
derived from ideas of that work.
So, I also agree that privacy
by design work in Canada
has been incredibly influential
and incredibly effective.
In terms of, I guess,
things that are sort of opportunities
or things that Canada, you know,
might I guess benefit from
paying more attention to,
you know, one that comes
to mind immediately is this
challenge of disclosure.
So, and this is not a
Canadian specific thing, but,
you know, at the municipal
level, at the provincial level,
at the federal level,
it can be very difficult for anyone
you know, a journalist,
a researcher, a regulator
a member of the public
to understand, you know,
the answer to two questions.
One question being, if their
data is being collected
and how it's being collected or used
as part of some kind
of algorithmic process,
and then two, what kind of
algorithmic process is being used
as part of, you know, a
governmental bureaucratic process.
And given that, you know,
Canada, as other countries, you know,
has a bunch of public institutions
that require transparency on these issues.
It's become incredibly
challenging for researchers
even to get a sense of
how different departments or institutions,
public institutions even,
are making use of algorithms to make
very consequential decisions
about people's lives.
So, as an example of something
I can think of, you know
the Toronto police was recently discovered
to be using Clearview AI,
a facial recognition tool,
that's very invasive.
And it was revealed as part of,
you know, a journalist looking
into the Clearview AI vendor.
And it wasn't anything that was disclosed
by Toronto police to the public, or,
you know, even to any other
sort of accountability board.
So there's a lot of
challenges with disclosure,
and with open and transparent
communication around,
when an algorithm is being used,
and if it affects you,
and if it's using your
data and things like that.
And I think that's a huge
challenge that Canada
also has to face as well.
And then I will say the other sort of
potential challenge that
Canadians will probably
need to encounter with
respect to policy making,
is also really having open
and honest conversations
around anti-racism, and
some of the issues with,
you know, with respect to
you know, the societal
dynamics that contribute
to some of the injustice
perpetuated by these algorithms.
That's something that in the U S,
just due to the weight of their history,
it's sort of a conversation
that flows a little bit easier,
and people are a little
bit more informed about it.
Whereas they find sometimes in Canada
it can be challenging to
allow the conversation to get
to that point with respect
to algorithmic deployment
and how that connects
to the way that algorithms
are designed and deployed.
So, yeah, that's what I would say
would maybe be a couple of challenges
to look forward to (chuckles),
in addition to the stuff that
Canada is doing very well at.
- Thank you so much.
Yes, much, much, much more work to be done
on both of those fronts.
So thank you so much Deborah.
Golnoosh, do you wanna speak a little bit
to what you think
what's working well,
where you think there
could be some improvements?
- Sure, first I want to thank you again
for inviting me out for this panel.
It's a pleasure to be here
and also get to know all these people.
I want to also mention one thing that
Deborah also mentioned about the AI,
the impact algorithm assessments
that is happening in Canada.
It's a very impressive
work that has been done.
But, I don't want to
repeat the same thing as she said.
So I'm going to actually mention something
which is kind of personal to me
that I'm very proud of.
And that actually,
I'm considering myself as
an international researcher.
I worked Europe, in China,
and different institutes in the U S
and the reason that actually
I moved to Canada, was the AI policy
about bringing international
talents to Canada.
So there are so many fundings,
and I'm so proud of it,
that there are so many fundings
for international
talents to come to Canada
and actually make this ecosystem
very attractive for researchers to come,
because they can come and actually work
with other talents as well.
And specifically for the
problems that I am interested
in is algorithmic discrimination.
We actually need international (chuckles)
people to come and think
about the solutions.
So this is the place that
I see so many advantages
of. like, there are even
advantages to international people
to come to Canada for this.
And I think that's one of the
reasons that Canada can be,
it is actually the leader,
but can be the one of the biggest leader
of the AI technology.
And the changes that I
want to also see is also
related to this, because,
for the fields, this fairness is
by nature is interdisciplinary.
And as you can see from
the panel (chuckles)
that we are talking about is
also from different backgrounds
because the problem needs
people coming from different
backgrounds to think about the solutions.
One of the things about the AI is that,
most of the research is
happening at the conferences.
So we have big conferences in AI,
like NeurIPS and I clear et
cetera, that are happening.
And because Canada is one
of the biggest AI ecosystem,
we are actually having these conferences
happening in Canada.
So for example, (murmurs)
happened in Canada for many years.
But one of the issues that I see is
that we should allow people
to come to these conferences
because we want to have
the solutions to be
from the researchers
from around the boards.
We cannot actually bring
all of them to come
and work and live in Canada,
but we can actually help them to come
to these conferences and
we can think about the solutions together.
So one of the problems
that I see is the problem
with the visa,
the issue that we have with the visa.
So I think we can actually
make some changes to
ease the path to bring
more people to Canada.
- Thank you Golnoosh, and your comments,
just thinking about it
from an international,
you know, researchers attraction
and also from conferences,
are just a perfect segway Jacques,
into your role at the international center
of excellence and the
global partnership on AI.
So why don't you join us now
and give us your thoughts
on the question before us.
- Yes, thank you very much for the time.
Thank you also for the opportunity to,
join this panel and be able to introduce
at least a very new
initiative on a global basis
which is called GPAI, the
Global Partnership on AI.
I'm sure I'm not the youngest on the panel
but I'm the newest one in the AI sector,
'cause as you mentioned before,
I come more from a legal
background and international level
that's very much linked with
the mission of the GPAI.
Also I'll add comments too
what Golnoosh just said.
But I think what's important
to understand first
in terms of the mission of the GPAI,
it's not directly focused
on developing AI policy,
because we have the privilege
of having has as a partner,
the OECD as part of the GPIA
and that's where the secretary
of the GPIA is situated.
But we are actually a bot
end of the policymaking.
First, you know, the mission of the GP is,
to move from theory to practice.
So we are developing solution
or experimenting potential solution
that will eventually
inform a policy maker.
And once those policies have been adopted,
then we are also at the other end,
trying to develop business models,
so that we will be able to implement that.
The way that this has been done
and in terms of talking about
the leadership of Canada,
for those who are not aware,
the Global Partnership on AI is,
initially an initiative
of Canada and France,
started through a transition
to the G7 presidency.
And I think it's another
great illustration
of how Canada is taking
a leadership position
on the adoption of responsibility.
I mean, everybody's aware of
the declaration of Montreal,
resonate quite a lot on
the international scene.
So I think that Canada
has a lot of credibility,
and the GP is one more example of how
our commitment to make
a strong contribution
to the development of responsible AI.
In terms of the specific
elements of the mission,
I think I would like
to link to the comments
on the international side.
I think that the mission of the GP is
not only to ensure
the adoption of responsible
AI, but to making sure
that it is done for the benefit of all
and more specifically in collaboration
and taking into consideration,
the interest of emerging
and developing countries.
So part of the mission of
GP will be to make sure
that we are inclusive of the voice
of the developing country,
but, we as (murmurs) and
I'll maybe I'll spend just
10 seconds explaining what
the center of expertise
boost the abbreviation that is (murmurs).
we are actually supporting
some of the expert group.
And one of them being the
responsible working group,
through their work to make sure they have
all the back office and the proper support
to be able to deliver on their ambitions
to deliver the impact as well
of the Global partnership.
But part of what we do
also will be to incorporate
within our own team,
international researcher
who comes from the developing countries.
So we have been in discussion
over the last few months
with the various government
institution in Canada,
to make sure we have the
proper financial support
to do that,
but that will be one of
the important contribution
also of the (murmurs),
to the positioning of the GP.
So I think that we'll
continue that conversation.
There's so much more to talk about
the Global Partnership
and the role of senior
within the Canadian AI ecosystem.
(murmurs) It's an illustration
of our leadership.
It's linked from before and
after the policy-making,
so it's very much part of a
continuum of implementation.
And I can answer more
questions about specific work
that we will be focusing
on for the coming year.
- Thank you Jacques, and I
know we'll get some questions
in the Q&A for more information
about some of those areas.
So thanks, we'll look into
that later in the panel.
Thank you all.
I think that really helps
to set the stage for,
some of the questions
that I think as a group
we would like to dive into a little bit.
And one of the things
that I've found useful
in thinking about AI and
AI policy is to really
understand specific use cases,
or specific sectors to really understand
what regulatory regimes
might already be in place,
but also what the policy
challenges might be.
So why don't we start with one of those.
Let's dig into the question
of facial recognition
or surveillance technologies a little bit.
It's clearly top of mind,
we saw it last week in terms of
the events in in Washington
that's very controversial.
There are all sorts of
initiatives underway
from all sorts of different
policy perspectives.
So I think the question
I'd be interested is,
what do you think policymakers
need to understand?
What is it about this
particular technology
that is problematic?
And, what if any guidance,
would you give them
as they start to think about
how this technology moving forward?
And Deborah why don't we start with you?
- Yeah, sure my favorite
topic (laughs loudly).
Yeah I think there's a lot of
really important things that
policymakers need to understand
about facial recognition.
Something that I start
off with is that it is,
you know, often grouped in
with other biometric tools,
such as fingerprinting
and other forms of sort of
being able to track humans
and surveil them using
their biometric information.
But there's a couple
interesting differences
with facial recognition.
So for one thing,
facial recognition almost
requires no interaction.
So my, you know, I can...
I don't upload my finger
print onto social media,
and I need to interact
with a particular device
in order for my fingerprint to be,
you know, uploaded somewhere.
Whereas with facial
recognition, we're very casual
with the way that we handle our face data.
We treat it differently
than we do other biometrics.
We're much less careful and that's
you can find someone's face quite easily
and that can be included
in any kind of database.
And also as I'm walking
through the street, you know,
a facial recognition camera can capture me
and it doesn't necessarily
have to notify me
that I'm now, you know,
captured and my image processed.
So there's a lot of
challenges with respect
to the lack of direct interaction
with facial recognition tools,
that makes consent very, very challenging.
The other thing about
facial recognition is that,
starting in about 2014
with the deep face model
that was developed by Facebook,
deep learning has been
sort of the primary method
of training models for facial recognition.
And that means that there's
this enormous data requirement
in order for modern day
facial recognition tools
to work effectively.
What this means is that
there's pretty much databases
of you know, millions of faces
required in order to train
in a really effective model to
detect particular attributes
or to, you know, a database
that is much larger than
you know, what you might
need for other sort
of biometric tools using
other types of methods.
So as a technology, it is quite particular
there are characteristics
of facial recognition that,
position it to be especially harmful
and challenging and dangerous.
And with respect to sort
of the policy directions
that I hope people take
with facial recognition,
you know, one direction that we saw,
I used to be a fellow
at the AI Now Institute
in New York university and,
a lot of the work that happened
in that space was around disclosure
like I had mentioned before.
Just understanding when facial
recognition is being used,
and enforcing a requirement where
if my face is included in a database,
that's then analyzed,
if my face is captured
in a way that, you know,
I'm not aware of, you know,
how do I get notified?
If the NYPD or another sort
of policing groups such as,
like I mentioned,
Toronto police was caught
using Clearview AI.
So if there's a institution
that affects me, you know,
how can I be included in
the process of, you know,
asserting my rights and
being even notified that,
you know, my police department
is using facial recognition.
So the simple question of disclosure
was something that had to be
really fought for in New York.
What that ended up being was the post act,
which was pretty much
an effort to force NYPD,
to disclose what kind of
surveillance technology
that they were using.
So I think that's an
undervalued policy strategy
is to just encourage
transparency and communication
with the general public about,
how an algorithm is being used
and when it's being used.
And then outside of that,
something that's also
not very well considered
or often ignored is this
idea of performance.
And that's been a lot of my work has been,
auditing these technologies
for performance
on different demographic groups.
So we've already seen in the U S you know,
at least two or three cases of individuals
with darker skin tone being misidentified
by facial recognition tools
and having their lives
really negatively impacted
as a result.
And then I guess the like
very final thing I'll say is,
and this is sort of,
the next wave of policy
interventions that we saw
after the audit work really became public,
was a move for restriction.
So, you know, there's
particular institutions
like I mentioned, police
departments is a good candidate
but also, you know, there's
been great work by the
The Citizen Lab at University of Toronto
that's done great work into
the use of facial recognition
and immigration processes
and things like that.
So there's a lot of cases where,
perhaps facial recognition is a tool
that should not be used ever.
So a lot of proposals for moratoriums,
and bans for particular
individuals or institutions
use of facial recognition
in a particular context
that's deemed, you know, too high stakes
or too sensitive for that
kind of technology to be used.
So yeah, I think those are
like three policy directions
that I often speak about
that I hope Canada
definitely embraces moving forward.
- Thank you so much.
Others who'd like to comment, Patricia.
- Yeah, I just thought that was excellent.
Thank you, Deborah.
I wanted to just add a little
bit of a postscript to,
the story about Clearview AI,
and comment a little bit
on the specific use case
that you presented Rebecca.
As some of you may know,
and Deborah alluded to this,
it came to light,
the assistance that
Clearview AI was providing to
police services across
Canada came to light and,
it led to an investigation
that is being conducted
by the Federal Commissioner
along with Quebec,
BC and Alberta,
are conducting a joint investigation.
Interestingly Clearview AI
pulled back and ceased
providing it services in Canada,
but the investigation is ongoing because
of the importance of,
producing a report,
given the stakes for Canadians privacy.
So it will be very interesting to watch.
I just wanna say
it's not the first investigation
on this specific use case.
If you recall, remember there
were the Vancouver riots
of 2011 following the Stanley Cup loss.
And, on the evening of that game
there were riots and many fans
riding in the streets of downtown
Vancouver had taken photos
and uploaded those to websites,
Facebook pages, et cetera.
And the police ensued with
an investigation that,
included the collection of
thousands of these images.
And the insurance corporation
of British Columbia had
developed FRT system,
originally developed for
reducing fraudulent acquisition
and use of driver's licenses
as part of the insurance process.
And they offered to assist the police
with the use of this technology,
and they had no compulsion to do so.
There was no subpoena, no
warrant, no court order,
and it led to an investigation
by the information and
privacy commissioner of BC.
And this was more than a decade ago.
And what's interesting
there was, you know,
one of the key issues that
the Commissioner raised
was the shift in use,
from a technology that had
been developed for the use
of detecting fraudulent
use of driver's licenses,
to actually investigating
criminal behavior post riot,
without any knowledge or
consent of the individuals,
let alone any adequate notice to citizens,
that this was being done.
And so I just wanted to point that out
'cause that is an interesting
use case here in Canada
more than a decade ago.
And the commissioner had this to say
about the use of this technology
without judicial authorization saying,
judicial oversight is necessary to ensure
that any changing use of this
magnitude is proportional
to the public good served
by the infringement
on privacy rights of citizens.
So there's a lot of empathy
and sympathy for the use
of FRT in the context in
which we saw that, you know,
the riots in the Capitol,
but I think there are also
compelling reasons to make sure
that the guardrails and, you know,
respect of human rights and civil rights
are protected in the process.
- Thank you Patricia.
Maybe I'll move on to another question
because I think both Deborah and Patricia,
your comments and advice with regards to
facial recognition and
surveillance technologies
really speaks to data.
And the way in which AI, and
AI systems like deep learning
use data and the requirement
have governments and
for companies to understand
how that data is used
and how it is used
differently when we think
about in terms of AI systems.
So I really would be
interested maybe beginning
with you Golnoosh to dig
into the question of,
what is it that you really
think that policy makers
need to know about how AI
systems use data differently
than other big data or
data analytics programming
and what should they be
considering when they think
about the use of AI in terms of either
products and services to citizens,
or private sector products
and services to customers?
- I want to also mention something about
like the applications that we discussed,
the face recognition.
It's not the only application,
that we see discrimination is happening.
So currently, like AI tools
are becoming part of the modern society.
So we are like, people are using it
in different scenarios every day.
Even the face recognition
is just not harmful
that you're using it in
law enforcement and policy.
And you can actually use it in like,
when people are coming to the door
and recognizing their
face and open the door.
The simple scenario as that,
it could be discriminatory, right?
So the issue is coming like
partially coming from a data
because we are living
in the era of big data.
We have access to large
amounts of datasets.
So from the social networks we have,
from the mobile data, we
have sensors, et cetera.
And also we have easy to use tools,
AI tools at the moment.
And the combination of these two,
means that we are creating
different applications,
different domains that people are using
without really considering
the consequences
of like these kinds of applications.
And now we have seen
like many negative impacts of those cases.
Then the issue is that like people are
or the companies are using this kind
of tools are not really aware
of like the data that we are using.
So they are not looking at the data
and the breakdown of the data
and maybe the respective
different sub groups.
So we have discrimination
partially coming from the fact
that we don't have the
representation of the population
in the data when we are
using these kinds of tools,
for the general population.
So we have like one group
that the model is trained based on it,
and we are applying to all
the groups in the society.
So that's one of the
issues that we can see
but, I want to mention like discrimination
is not just because of the data.
So models can learn those
kind of behaviors from a data
because of the stereotypes,
because of the historical discrimination
and can actually amplify it.
So it's not just learning
it and doing the same thing,
it can actually amplify it.
But unfortunately, I should say that
like the way that these
kind of models are designed
they could actually
introduce biases as well.
So it's not the fact that like,
if you are cleaning the data,
if you don't have any issue with the data,
the model itself is going to be clean.
So we have to consider that discrimination
can happen at both sides
and that's why we need the solutions
with respect to that.
I also wanted to mention about that,
the issue about AI.
AI is a kind of a vague term.
The problem is that fairness by definition
is interdisciplinary and also subjective.
So in different domains
we have to actually
define what does it mean
that is discriminatory.
And we do have law against
discrimination, of course.
But the issue is that it's designed
to be vague (laughs loudly).
So it's a law for
different interpretations
but then you're coming to the case of AI,
as a researcher, as a computer scientist,
you actually need a definition
which is deterministic.
And that's why this kind of interpretation
of coming from a legal
document into the AI system
it's kind of hard.
So we know we have issues with data.
We know we have issues with AI tools
with respect to discrimination,
but coming up with a
solution for that is going
to be very hard,
because of it is very subjective.
You have to define it for
different disciplines,
different stakeholders, what does it mean
that it's fair or not,
and that's the hard problem to solve.
But it doesn't necessarily mean that
we cannot solve it (chuckles),
because the issue that we are
facing is the issue of today.
And if you are not finding the solution
even a good solution,
not the perfect solution,
today we are actually facing
the systematic discrimination
which is far worse than the discrimination
that we had before the society.
We are dealing with
the harm that is going to be systematic.
And we have to actually
deal with it today.
- Thank you, would others like to comment
on those issues that Golnoosh has raised
before we move into a
Q&A with the audience?
- Yeah, maybe just very briefly
if you allow me Rebecca.
Just to connect maybe to
the international context
the one that
I'm living in through
the GP and (murmurs),
but I think that those biases
that have been referred to,
also in the way...
Especially when we talk
about the developing
or emerging countries,
you know, there are a lot
of those when they implement
or try to implement some of
those technology processes
you know, in, in developing countries,
the level of bias, you know,
the risk of bias has
increased because of the fact
that there was a lack of
input data in that process.
So that's one element.
The other element also which is
one that could have an influence is
the difference of the
cultural environment in which,
you know, some of those
technologies are being implemented
and the implication that they might have
or the perception it might have
from a cultural point of view also.
I think that when the GP was designed,
the idea is that first,
in terms of having as
many voices as possible
represented at the table,
it's a multi-sectorial.
So we have private sector, civil society
as well as scientists and academics
are at the table,
so that all of the point of view...
But the idea is also as I mentioned before
is to bring at the table
the voices of developing
countries and emerging countries,
so that these are developed thinking
taking into consideration the fact
that they might need to be adapted
and it's already built in, you know,
in the design that they will be adaptable
to those specific contexts recognizing
where those differences might be.
- Thank you, Deb?
- Yeah I just had a quick addition
which was another sort of dimension of
data's relationship with like AI,
especially modern tools which,
lean heavily on machine
learning and deep learning
in particular is just the
resource allocation required.
So, you know, data sets used
in modern machine learning
and AI systems are very, very large,
and that requires,
it's very resource
intensive to train a model
and deploy a model.
And as a result of that there's
very specific power dynamics
that come out of that.
There's a lot of environmental risk,
but also it's really hard to control,
very, very large datasets
and things that are sort of only,
I guess projects and a
culture, which we do have
in machine learning of
just only focusing on,
collecting as much data as possible
leads to a lot of the
mistakes that were mentioned
by the others around not doing a good job
adapting to a specific domains,
not doing a good job
representing the population
that it's gonna be deployed on.
And this is, you know,
one of the causes of this
is definitely just the
sheer volume of data
usually required for
these systems to work.
- Good point thank you.
Okay, so let's turn to
one of the questions
from the audience.
I'm actually gonna pull a
couple together here because,
this really interesting thing
we've been talking about,
the rapid advancement and
innovations in the technology
and policy and the difference in speed.
And so the question of,
how can policy be used to
advance innovation to
actually support innovation
to create a policy
environment where there is
responsible innovation is one
of the questions that's come in
and whether that touches on data
or international efforts or otherwise.
And I wonder, Patricia,
can you talk a little bit
about that in terms of
how you see that interplay
between policy and innovation
and the role of the commissioner?
- Sure, I think there's
an important role for
different forms of policy.
Deborah talked about
agile forms of policy,
I'll speak to in a moment.
But I think at the very basic level,
there is a foundation of statutory policy
that's required to set
the level playing field
for all competitors, to play fair,
responsibly and to spirit on innovation.
So you talked about, for instance, C-11.
C-11 is a much needed
effort, federal bill,
that's been tabled to modernize
the federal act PIPEDA,
which is lagging behind in many respects
in terms of its capacity to deal with,
some of the challenges of
artificial intelligence,
data analytics that were never anticipated
when it was adopted
more than 20 years ago.
One of the big advantages of PIPEDA
was that it was principles
based, from the very outset
which allowed it to survive this long
but even those principles
have been overtaken
and is in need of modernization.
The good news is,
C-11 is principle based as well.
There are provisions in
there that deal specifically
with automated decision systems.
So there's certainly some really important
modernizations there that will help
spur on innovation and
provide predictability
for innovators in this space.
So that's a good thing.
There's a flexible mechanisms for instance
of permitting consent exemptions,
for responsible use
and collection of data.
And along with that comes
enhanced transparency requirements
stronger accountability mechanisms,
the right to an explanation,
the possibility to
also spur stronger enforcement
triggering stronger
enforcement mechanisms.
So all of that is part of a package.
I think from a statutory perspective
that's important to form the base.
But along with that,
what's important also is
that the bill allows for
other forms of policy.
More agile responses such
as codes of practice,
certification programs,
where industry itself
the innovators itself can
develop sector specific guidance
that with the approval
of the commissioner,
then allow them as long as they comply
with that code approved or
that commissioner approved code
of practice within the
certification program,
they are given or provided certain level
of immunity from downstream
penalties that could be imposed.
So this is the kind of complimentary forms
of industry specific compliance mechanisms
that I think are very important
in an innovative space.
The other forms of self
regulatory mechanisms
are the data privacy
impact assessments or PIAs,
or the algorithmic impact assessments
in the space of AI
that are incredibly important
and indispensable part
of a robust privacy management
program, where again
innovators can take
matters in their own hands,
in order to, you know,
develop the baseline that
will engender the trust needed
to enable adoption of these technologies.
So I'll leave it at that.
I can talk for hours, but I think that
I think we need both.
I think we need statute based
law that forms the principles
the baseline principles,
and we need these mechanisms
for compliance initiatives
from the industry sectors themselves,
to compliment those statutes.
- Thank you so much.
I really do feel like
we could keep talking
for much more time.
There's many more questions
that we all have and lots
more information to share.
Jacques, I want to give you one minute
because there's been a number of questions
that have come in in the
Q&A about how individuals
can get involved with the
global partnership on AI.
Can you in sort of 30 seconds or less
just touch on where they should go,
and what they should if
they want to learn more?
- Yes, sure, first where they should go,
two things, there's a
website for the GPAI,
so gpai.ai, and I can share
that on the chat after,
and then there's also a webpage for
the (murmurs), which will be, you know,
improved over time.
But that's the two easy access
to get more information.
In terms of how individual
can be involved,
first, within the the
terms of reference the GP,
there will be a mechanism where
expert who would like to be joining
one of the working groups, could
actually be self nominated.
There will be a selection process,
so not everybody will be
selected, but there will be.
And that process will be developed
over the next couple of months,
so please keep an eye on the GPIA website
for more information on that.
The same also as we
support the working groups
through their projects
over the coming years
will be and there has been
in the past five months,
if you call for proposal,
for individuals to come
and assist, you know,
bring their expertise to the group.
So again, keep an eye on our website.
And we also use our partners website
to be able to like see
far, to publicize that.
But that's another way where
there will be opportunities.
Plus, you know, we'll have
interns program within the task
so that there will be
multiple opportunities
for individual in Canada to join forces
and bring their expertise at the table.
- Fabulous, thank you.
To be continued with all of you.
I hope we have an
opportunity soon to reconvene
and to pick up on so many
of the topics we started
and those we will want
to continue to talk about
in this very important area of work.
Thank you all, Merci.
It's been wonderful to be
with you this afternoon.
That concludes our policy panel for today.
(upbeat music)